the u.n secretary general kicked off the
10th review conference of the npt by
sounding the alarm
today humanity is just one
misunderstanding when miscalculation
away from nuclear annihilation
we have been extraordinarily lucky so
far but luck is not a strategy his
pessimism stands in sharp contrast to
when russia and the united states signed
on to the treaty in 1970. this is indeed
an historic occasion it was the height
of the cold war and the goal was to
prevent a nuclear conflict nations of
the world
moved from a period of confrontation to
a period of negotiation and a period of
lasting peace as recently as january the
five permanent members of the u.n
security council who also happen to be
the officially recognized nuclear weapon
states the united states the united
kingdom russia china and france all
pledged not to further disseminate
nuclear weapons but
a month later russia invaded ukraine
while russia claims full compliance with
the npt others consider that a threat
and it's engaged in reckless dangerous
nuclear saber rattling
with its president warning that those
supporting ukraine self-defense
quote risk
consequences such as you have never seen
in your entire history
and then there's the iran nuclear deal
agreed in 2015 it was heralded as a step
toward reducing proliferation until the
u.s withdrew now iran says it has enough
uranium to build a nuclear weapon
while few nations have gone as far as
north korea and trying to build them
anti-nuclear campaigners say other
countries are expressing a new
willingness to host them as a deterrent
that's what frightens valeria hess a
nuclear expert from ukraine attending
the conference
so
there is
a widespread belief
that nuclear weapons have prevented a
big war
and it turned out not to be true
signatories to the npt are meant to
gather every five years in an attempt to
advance the goal of disarmament this
year thanks to global tensions experts
say there's little hope of action
kristen sulumi al-jazeera the united
nations